good afternoon everyone and it's my
pleasure to welcome you to building
partnerships and legal scholarship law
libraries and the center for digital
research and scholarship can everyone
hear me okay is this loud enough okay
and I am delighted to introduce our
panelists today starting from your right
my left adana knock shoe librarian and
lecturer in law at the Columbia Law
School Library Larry Abraham who is the
head of instructional services at the
Fordham University Law School Library
and Rebecca Kennison who is the director
of the center for digital research and
scholarship at Columbia University thank
you trying to understand our problems in
terms of building partnerships in legal
scholarship and it all started not so
long ago maybe in the 90s when the web
became a prevalent powerful partner a
disruptive partner in more way than one
in terms of its influence over legal
scholarship and this is a quote that
Rebecca brought to my attention and I
think it's a very useful to keep in mind
because indeed despite the fact that
legal scholarship is an enterprise that
is very much conservative and its rules
of citation are extremely conservative
and they try to be limited to whatever
is in print we cannot ignore the fact
that more and more resources are
available online and our researchers are
going to incorporate those fickle online
sources and how that is going to affect
us is something that we are going to
partially address today so challenges
and opportunities for legal scholarship
from Fordham Law Library Larry is going
to talk to us about supporting
interdisciplinary research
needs and maybe the problems raised by
that aspect and here from the Columbia
angle we are going to talk about how we
can support legal scholarship production
and I'm going to talk about the pre
publishing level and we'll give you a
little bit of insight of the conundrums
attached to that process and then
Rebecca is going to illuminate everybody
of with what's going on at the
publishing level so I'm going to let
Larry talk about the fordham experience
and the impact of interdisciplinarity
thank you very much Donna first of all
I'd like to say what a pleasure it is to
be back at Columbia where I spent many
happy and occasionally a few productive
hours as an undergraduate and law
student and where I was inspired to
become a librarian so if there are any
cambia librarians of the audience thank
you i'm here to talk about interpret is
interdisciplinary scholarship in law
schools from librarians perspective I
guess the first thing that has to be
said is that um to great extent it's
really not what say 25 years ago law
schools and law librarians had signed on
for the hallmark of legal scholarship up
until fairly recently was people who
were alerted in the law and almost
exclusively in the law attempting to
figure out what the law stood for what
it meant and that sort of thing however
in laws and many other scholarly
disciplines the the trend is very much
towards interdisciplinarity to the
extent that increasingly faculty hiring
in law schools is not just among people
who possess law degrees but people who
also possess PhDs and are interested in
sort of raising among other academics
the level of academic seriousness of
legal scholarship since to a first
approximation PhDs in law don't really
exist there are s JD's but those aren't
considered sort of on the same level as
as PhD is by
the people who hold the PhDs we sort of
end up in a situation where we have to
hire people who where we want to hire
people we being the law schools in
general not the libraries where we want
to hire people who have these scholarly
interests developed in PhD programs and
that puts a strain on the law school
librarian because the law school
librarian most likely is a dual degree
librarian has been trained in in law and
in librarianship but because of the
increasing interdisciplinarity of legal
scholarship is now called on not just to
have two areas of expertise but even
more so how have we dealt with that what
have we done about that it occurs to me
now that looking at my slide it's really
sort of I've really sort of put things
backwards I also we put the liaison
program first let me spend about 15 20
seconds on the liaison program it's
fairly common in law schools that every
member of the faculty is assigned an
individual librarian at Fordham it's not
just reference librarians it's every MLS
holder in the building because we just
need everybody we can get is assigned a
librarian who's primarily responsible
for reading that person's point of
contact for anything from getting
material on reserve to the sort of thing
we're talking about here intense
research experiences and the way we
account for interdisciplinarity in the
liaison program is to attempt to match
the librarians because of previous work
experience previous academic experience
or just sort of luck to the to the
interdisciplinary academic interests of
their liaison faculty we try to do that
through through grouping that's very
popular for us you know one of one of my
colleagues is it has masters in
economics so we try to give her the end
experience part of me also as a
corporate lawyer so we try to give her
all of the corporate faculty which sort
of makes sense from a straight loss
sense you know she really understands
the securities laws and somebody who had
worked as a family law practitioner
wouldn't but also she really has a keen
understanding of economics and economic
the economics literature and that sort
of thing so that she can support that
kind of interdisciplinary scholarship it
leads of course to a which of course
leads to the problem what do we do when
someone has an interdisciplinary
interest in which none of us has any
specialty and then basically we punt and
hope for the best the other thing about
that's very interesting in what we're
doing in a discipline not exactly
interdisciplinary but similar to it is
we've created an increased emphasis on
empirical research in law to the great
to great extent the tradition and legal
scholarship is sort of great theorizing
about what the law to meet at how it
ought to work in making normative claims
that can't possibly be tested and again
over the last 25 years that's evolved to
the extent where people wish to prove
empirically what they're doing so we
have created an empirical specialist
position within the library and as we
were hiring for that position we sort of
really thought carefully about whether
we wanted a person who is an empiricist
first and a librarian second a person
who was a librarian first an empiricist
second or a person who was a librarian
first and last that had some
understanding of empiricism and the
conclusion we came to was that you know
sort of in this it was that whatever
partnerships we created we sort of had
to create among ourselves because the
needs of our library in the size of our
staff were such that we couldn't
literally couldn't afford to have
somebody who was purely focused on in
Paris and unable to serve as a
traditional reference librarian so we
sort of squared the circle and instead
of creating a partnership we sort of
created the skills among ourselves the
other
way we engage in partnership is and it's
it's sort of partnership but it's more
like the partners I don't know exactly
how to describe the partnership now that
i think about it but it has to do with
the first thing that i mentioned on on
my slide over here which is the means by
which we acquire or choose not to
acquire materials the support
interdisciplinary scholarship the fort
of approach to acquisitions is somewhat
unusual we don't have subject
specialists I mean you could make the
reasonable argument that we're all legal
librarians and therefore we're all
subject specialists but we don't even
have subspecialties it's not like
somebody's doing everything with
somebody's doing all the family law
selection and somebody's doing all of
the selection of law for the southern
hemisphere that sort of thing we all do
it together everybody has their own
expertise but we all do it together we
get together every two or three weeks
pretty much all of the professional
librarians in the library and we say
okay these are the books were buying
this week or these are the serials we're
getting rid of or whatever it is we
happen to be doing that week and one of
the questions that always comes up in
the acquisition of materials that aren't
strictly law has to do with what we
think with our best guess as to what the
university libraries are going to do
because one of the ways in which we
manage interdisciplinary scholarship and
participation is to rely to great extent
on the university libraries to provide
that those things that it's economically
inefficient for us to provide ourselves
but that kind of cop economically
inefficient in the sense that they would
charge us just as much they're going to
charge the university libraries even
though they serve a much larger
community and economically inefficient
in the sense that we get access to
everything they have
that set of considerations though opens
us up and look mostly willingly to sort
of what we see is the flip side of the
equation which is that that that you
know just as much as legal scholars are
interested in doing wha and scholars of
other discipline that other disciplines
are interested in doing and law and by
and by relying on those good folks we
sort of end up in a situation by relying
on those good folks we sort of end up in
a situation in which we're getting a lot
of incoming traffic as well as providing
our outgoing traffic and we manage that
relationship mostly informally but it
seems to work anyway I muddling through
would probably be an probably be an
excessively reductive way to put it but
basically what we're doing is figuring
out a way by cooperating as librarians
with other librarians to get everybody
everything they need thanks very much
Thank You Larry and what I think Larry
was able to let us see is how complex
legal scholarship is it's not just going
to a statute a copyright statute for
example and the describe how it was
passed and its implications and whatever
case law came up out of it so everything
now is getting more and more on the
complex and more difficult to support so
I'm going to talk about the
peculiarities of legal scholarship not
from its content point of view which I
let Larry give you a taste of it but
from its practical aspect so most of you
have published in your life in some
format or not at a minimum on the web on
your blog but if you do with them
professionally there is an editor whose
job is to edit your work you submit your
work that editor is going to work with
it
and after that it's going to be
published by a professional publisher
and Rebecca knows the ins and out of
that process much more than I do and I
don't want to make up anything but when
we talk about legal scholarship we talk
about student edited journals and what's
very interesting for a faculty member a
low faculty member in order to obtain
tenure that faculty member has to
publish in those student edited journals
not books they don't count for tenure
but journals are journal articles from
my point of view I'm very disturbed by
that because there is a hierarchy of
journals and guess who is considered to
be at the top journals from very
conservative law schools which happened
to be ranked at number one two three
four five all right the ranking just
came up so you can go and see if Kenny
is ms miling yell is number one we are
number four at Columbia Law School and
our students are going to publish the
work of their professors and we are
going to perpetuate the scholarship that
comes from these top a tiered schools
and just to give you an idea of how
things work with a legal scholarship
this is a list of all the journals out
there there may be about a thousand you
know we usually include Canada as our
51st state and as UC student edited peer
edited and refereed and you would be
amazed that peer edited are a third
maybe of all the journals contained here
so most of them are student edited this
is adjuster ranking alphabetically
organized but we can play around and see
what's going on I'm going back to to my
problems in addition to the fact that so
student edited journals
are the repositories of legal
scholarship there is an additional
problem that i'm going to talk about the
impact of annual turnaround of editorial
boards because students are part of
these editorial boards just for a
limited amount of time so let's say that
you have an editor who is excellent
learned how to edit your piece but
within a year that student is gone so
you have a new set of students who have
to familiarize themselves with the rules
of editing and many of those rules are
quite style related and those rules are
published in something that we call the
blue book because it has a blue cover
and so forth so I don't know if you can
get a sense of the tension that's there
between content and the practicality of
publications of publishing journals so
here comes Rebecca as a life savior from
my position as a librarian who has to
train these editors in the blue book
rules of how your site they come to them
a library to understand I have to give
you a little bit more of a background
here if I say that this chair is blue in
any publication that will be sufficient
or if I say that the archer is good for
sitting that will be sufficient you will
accept my statement not when it comes to
legal scholarship I have to footnote
that statement I have to hope that Kenny
has published an article about the value
of that chair and I can footnote that
article that gives credence and value to
my statement so what's going on the
footnotes make an article valuable and
those students who are the editors on
those editorial boards come to the
librarian and ask us for help in order
to identify those obscure sources that
are going to give credence to the
article they chose to publish in their
journal and we have to train those as
students year in and year out because
there is no way around it in addition to
that they are going to ask the library
in the librarian to borrow books or
borrow articles and we help them create
a shelf collection so we have printouts
or the physical book and I put them on a
shelf which seems to me a bit Luddite
when we can scan the article or scan the
page and create those digital shelf
collections and that's part of the pre
publication process I'm talking about
and my collaboration with a CD RS in
terms of how they support our pre
publication process now there are many
impediments in additional to what I told
you impediments that are related to the
nature of legal scholarship there also
administrative impediments because who
is going to help these journals the
library the CD RS the law school the
journal itself which is incorporated
quite often and my position since I've
been here has been that the library
should become a partner and support the
publication of journals and we have the
expertise and this is our role we have
to reinvent our role in in terms of
supporting legal scholarship and this is
one of the roles and no one wants to
take is our to grab and sometimes that
works sometimes it doesn't work so from
my position of a library a librarian who
wants to support the publication of
these journals comes this idea of a
digital shelf collection and my begging
and the generous response i received
from rebecca and the CD RS yes here we
have this product called al fresco a
platform that allows you to upload
whatever documents you want and create
your own protected library of sources to
give you another sense you saw that list
of
hundreds of journals many of them are
specialized as Larry at larry young as
Larry mentioned that you would have a
scholarship in family law or corporate
law or law in economics there are
journals that mirror that types those
types of research interests and imagine
if you publish something in a
specialized journal you tend to use the
same resources to support your statement
if I'm interested in the chair
scholarship I'm going to refer to
kenya's article about that chair whether
I want to publish an article today or
tomorrow or and so forth so the value of
having a digital collection of all those
resources is that libraries don't have
to spend that much money on an
interlibrary loan request because there
everything is protected by password
alfresco offers that the option so we
won't have to run into any copyright
problems not so ever so I'm going to try
to show you let's see if it works and
after that I'm going to let Rebecca
explain to you more about what CD RS is
we don't have we do have yes it's
whether we have or not internet
connection in return so it's very easy
you're going to log in and you're going
to find your site search for sites and
it's very easy to find look I'm going to
do just an elf for example anything and
they're going to tell me that I'm
involved in all these journals and I'm
going to click on the Columbia journal
of law and race Rebecca is going to talk
more about the CDR support of the
publication aspect this is the
pre-publication the kitchen work before
you serve the meal you go and prepare
the meal this is what I'm showing you so
you can have a document library where
you can upload everything that you need
in order to a very
if I the statements that an author makes
in an article you can have a calendar
and you can give assignments to your
editorial board and put those
assignments there you can have what I
like links for example to whatever sites
you are going to use in order to check
check Pegasus see if the library has a
site and them has a source that you are
interested in discussion the members you
can invite everybody to become a member
a wiki a wiki where you can post
whatever rules you have and of course a
blog and you are going to say whatever
you want to say everything is here the
only problem that people are raised
about alfresco and this may be something
alfresco is not on a cloud so al fresco
is on Columbia server which is good it
is good because it's safe is protected
is going to be here forever what's bad
about it from the students point of view
is that they cannot work on a document
and have real-time exchanges at the same
time I open a document that's here Larry
can open it and make changes and Rebecca
make changes in the same way that
Dropbox works if you are familiar with
that with that platform so this may be
something I suspect that we can work
around and we can improve the product
but the benefit that alfresco gives you
is just amazing so I'm going to let
Rebecca explain to us how cd-rs supports
the publishing aspect when the meal is
being served thank you
thanks Donna and Larry so I think you're
getting a bit of a flavor for if you
didn't know legal scholarship before and
how it worked that it's quite quite
quite different from the way that we
normally have thought of the scholarly
communication system that you go you
maybe work with collaborators you write
a paper you submit it to a journal goes
to the peer review process it eventually
sees the light of day out at the other
out of the other end it's been
fascinating for me because I know
nothing about didn't know really
anything about how how legal scholarship
was published and I mean who hasn't
heard of you know harvard law review or
something of course we all have that
this is published by and edited by
students you might have paid attention
to that particularly when Obama was
famously the editor of Columbia was it
Columbia no Harvard Harvard see I don't
even that's right I'm just trying to
stir up trouble by mentioning Obama in
columbia in the same that's right I'm
very delighted he's going to Barnard
just missing Bonnie strong partner so
I'm one of the things that when i was
starting at the center for digital
research and scholarship which is within
the libraries here at columbia i like to
say i'm not a librarian but I put play
when conferences then kale for having me
here is one of one of the many things
that we do at Cedars is support journal
publishing and one of the area's first
areas that we got into in part because
Kenny Kenny is Kenny's like the fourth
member of our panel here one of the
things that big thick the Kenny did was
he he actually introduced us to two
people over at the law school who were
very interested in having some of that
support from for
group that could provide that coherence
that the dont was talking about is
normally there's a yearly churn the
editors are coming in they're very
interested in doing the editing but they
don't really know anything about
publishing or or editing or or really
anything in the process and so Donna
takes them and and the other members of
the of the law school library staff
really helped them to work through that
whole bit at the beginning you know what
what are you doing how are you doing it
and then we at the back end helped
provide that that coherence that
cohesion of last year's editors what did
they saw and what agreements did they
sign with with high in online or
whatever what what did they do in the
past what do what would you like to do
in the future this year with your
journal while you have it for one year
and so I think we we do a very good team
approach which is why we we thought it'd
be interesting to talk about what we're
doing so this these are the 14 there are
14 law reviews here at Columbia these
are the 14 that some some you may have
heard of some you may not have heard of
and I think probably there's a new law
review that that starts every year or so
i think that's that's a fair to say so
the ones that were hosting ourselves so
the ones that we work very closely with
the editors and they're on our platform
being hosted by the center for digital
research and scholarship at columbia are
the ones that are just highlighted here
and we have a variety of levels that we
that we host at so there are 7 of the 14
that we have one of those as under
discussion but the rest of those were
being we're hosting those so the
extended level and I gave you guys a
hand out and the video people don't get
a hand up but I gave
gave you a handout so that would break
down for you what these various levels
are but an extended level is really a
very high level we support everything
that goes on at the at the business law
review so we did the design work we host
their text we help them with really
everything soup to nuts that they want
to do the basic level which is where
most people are that's that we said
that's we set up a website for them and
we help them to work within that system
give them training for the most part
we're using WordPress blogs to help them
out and then simple and design that's
that's a design function there so
variety of those this kind of just
breaks down what those levels are that
they get to come when they when an
editor comes and again this is a
year-by-year process so a new editor
comes in it's as if we're starting all
over again with a new journal so they
don't know anything about what their
predecessors did they don't know
anything about running a journal they
don't know anything of it they don't
like the design that the previous
editors chose they want to do something
completely different they have
historical ebid imprint and now they've
finally decided that they want to enter
the 21st century to be honest we don't
have very many of those still although
that was the original goal was that we
would help everybody to get online so
buy online they now I mean they put
their abstracts up and and here you can
buy the print copy I'm sure donning and
Larry can both talk more about that but
we do try very much to encourage those
people who come on board with us to
think very differently about what 21st
century a publication looks like and so
again we have a conversation with the
editors they tell us what they want they
tell us what they envisioned and and
then we decide which level of service to
provide and we are not a cost recovery
service and so consequently
we give them a very reasonable even for
those things that say fee we give them a
very reasonable rate to to play around
with and sometimes they go away and say
wow that's too much and you know I have
some bit of a friend who will do web
design for a hundred dollars for me and
and and so that's that's fine if they
want to do that we will also just host
the journals for them and they can they
can bring their own designers and to do
the work as well so very very flexible
in terms of what we will provide for
them but again the most important thing
is and the reason that we would love to
have all 14 journals come on board is
that a coherence and cohesion year after
year after year where they don't have to
worry about you know who registered
their domain with whom and in what name
and five years from now they lose their
domain because somebody's left Columbia
use their Columbia ideas their contact
information and so on so and we do this
beyond the law journals with law
journals as a collection and collective
are the largest number of journals that
we have we're hosting about 20 journals
of which seven right now or law journals
so that said you know beyond the hosting
of journals themselves Donna's already
talked to you about alfresco you can see
the alfresco members here but sorry but
there are 10 journals listed here again
I told you 14 so we touch ten of the 14
which is pretty excellent you know
number of touches that we have on here
and some of them we're hosting some of
them are just using alfresco several of
them are appearing in academic commons
which is our institutional repository
and they are depositing once a year so
we might not be hosting them but they're
giving us their content to to keep and
preserve and ancho and so and again it
really really depends on what the
editors want and we work very act
Lee with it with our partners at the you
know in the library in particular to to
really get people more and more to come
on board and we've had very good success
with that so so we've gone kind of from
the big picture of of you know the whole
way that scholarship works and drilled
down to you know how are you going to
get that that article online out of al
fresco and up so I think that's it how
do we do one so you can open it up to
questions now we do have some time
anyone has cushions how have you seen
cd-rs assistant interdisciplinary
process of the pre-publication are you
seeing so because of your collaboration
with journals not just in the law school
but possibly in the other areas finding
ways to put those two together because
of the shared process a lot of the of
the process that we do within our Center
is is not naturally interdisciplinary
shall we say but it but the law journals
in particular are increasingly
interdisciplinary and so and so we have
the journals of a race in law for
example and it used to be that's a
reformulated journal that used to be the
National Black lawd review-journal
something I can't remember what's
reviewed journal which is now which is
now being hosted by another group
because the editors within that journal
wanted to expand it well beyond just
national black and make it much more
about race and law around the world make
it much more interdisciplinary bring in
a variety of voices there I think that's
a that's a really good example of how
the editors is they're coming in
really thinking differently about how to
do that work now what makes that kind of
interesting from the point of view of
what Donna did maybe she can talk a bit
about that too is is that those
citations that right now are
individually assigned to a journal those
those shelves that are now you know
digital shelves sharing across that and
allowing for people who might be within
one journal to take a look at what an
editor in another journal has done
that's a total possibility within the
framework that we that we've worked with
daughter two setups yes if I may add
that's the beauty of alfresco because
you can invite someone else from another
Department to view your document so
indeed that was also the attraction the
major attraction of alfresco you are
going to say that Google Documents can
do that the major impediment of Google
Documents is its limited space while at
first co has no limitation and also
don't have to worry about who's contact
information is down and so forth so the
continuity and in terms of
interdisciplinarity yes you can be a
scientist and have access to alfresco
and you are going to be invited by their
own administrator of the site and as I
said unlike Google Docs you can post
your video or whatever resource you are
going to use because al fresco has the
resources to so is this limited to a
columbia university faculty and students
or can you invite oh we like you we can
invite anybody yes that's the beauty of
it and I just spoke to rebecca about it
or what would happen if someone who
opened a site here would leave and go to
another academic institution and rebecca
said that that's the purpose of seeders
to support so there are some limitations
on
at Columbia as well as I'm sure most
most other places in terms of
collaboration alfresco is one of several
collaboration systems that Cedars hosts
for for faculty and staff and grad
students to be able to do collaboration
outside it increasingly in in a global
environment almost everybody is outside
of columbia in fact the the medical
campus is somewhat considered outside of
columbia even in terms of the the way
that structures inch being able to share
files so and we run a couple of systems
one is wiki scholars which is also open
to you have to be at Columbia and order
set up the account but after that as an
administrator you can you can invite
anybody that you want to I'm the same
thing as true of alfresco the difference
between those is wiki's scholars is a
very much of a wiki solution and
alfresco is much of it very much of a
document management system so that's one
reason that you can't just share to
write together because the purpose of al
fresco is version control so Donna's
writing and I can't override what she's
doing I can't make changes she checks it
out she writes it she checks it back in
I check it out I write some more I check
it in Larry checks it out and so on so
it's a very strict version control
system it's used by big enterprise
groups for the most part in order to
really do to some document management it
also has the ability though and this is
where where it's used quite often by
researchers who want to share
collections of research that they're
doing because it's such a small group
that's getting to look at those things
then it's just like but much better than
sending
a PDF to your colleagues or something so
we try we try very hard to to help
everybody be as as global and as
interacting with each other as possible
so how much do on law schools
collaborate on their journals in general
I mean from school to school I mean just
Fordham not at all they don't really do
that sorry that's sort of not a very
nuanced answer in terms of an accurate
but accurate I'm sure the the not only
do they not really collaborate with each
other from school to school they don't
collaborate intra school either I mean
it's not quite to the point of view
where they sort of acidic they're all
sort of on the same hallway at Fordham
and it's not quite like they're you know
sort of sniping at each other from their
offices but sometimes uncomfortably
close but there is a great deal of
collaboration because almost invariably
the author of the piece isn't from the
school that's publishing that's
publishing the piece the article is
proposed by a by a professor at Fordham
and it's published in the law review at
Columbia and exactly how the breakdown
of responsibility for some of these more
complicated issues works is is always
difficult to figure out we try to give
the maximum support to our student
journal members so that they don't have
to sort of rely on the professors and
the professors home institutions but by
contrast if one of our professors comes
in and says well the kids from whatever
Journal can't find the sites for my p's
help me we do it so there's there's a
good deal of collaboration on the
article production process but there's
not a lot of formal collaboration among
journals and then we skipped over the
whole very odd way that reviews of legal
scholarship happened almost all of them
now use a commercially run system called
expressive espresso yeah depending on
which saw
you're looking at there it's also called
etiquette and whatever but done run out
of B press in California and basically
look you know if I right you guys will
correct me if I'm wrong here my
understanding me is if I if I maybe if I
write an article I can submit it into
that system and I can say here the ten
journals that I'd really be interested
in publishing this piece in ranked 1 to
10 and then the editors get notified
that here's a here's an article that
they should review and they can review
somebody can come back and maybe their
number 6 on my list my list as the
author and and so I can then say oh I
really wanted to be in you know in in
the Harvard Law Review and Columbia
accepted me but I really want to be in
harvard and so right to the editor and
say hey are you guys still are you guys
considering my piece and so on so
there's a so it's not it's like antique
collaboration if i can put it that way
it's very competitive but it's all
within this one system which makes sense
within that within that system because
you're kind of bidding off against each
other and trying to up your own ranking
within where you want to publish so yes
I think that is amazing perfect hang on
yes I cut this short but technically the
refreshment session is starting now so
what we could do is if you want maybe we
could have room for one more question
and then if you wanted to continue the
conversation maybe we can all kind of
migrated over to the next room and just
informally talk but if there's another
question we could fit another one in it
would be lovely if someone had a
question but my ego need my ego does not
need you to think I'm better than
cookies yeah about Fordham libraries now
I know Fordham Law is at the lincoln
center location but the word on campus
is in the Bronx and you just talked
about the acquisition the way you do
acquisitions is kind of different and
that you collaborate with your fellow
librarians alone weekly basis or
something
like that and decide what comes and goes
does this include the bronx campus and
now and this is this is purely within
the law library itself so how about
resources for law school students from
the bronx campus there are no law school
students at the bride oh how do we get
resources from the bronx campus to the
law schools and do you have any input in
that if you're you know increasing your
intellectual property yeah we sort of we
sort of as an informal matter let them
know what we're doing and they is a sort
of informal matter let us know what
they're doing but relationships between
law schools and universities are rarely
Placid and I'll leave it at that if
you'd like further detail we'll talk
later as I always tell my students as I
always tell my students when somebody
when somebody sends you an email asking
you an interesting question the only
appropriate responses I'll call you back
you